foreign
comes from Jim in Florida I'm struggling
and giving recently because I have plans
that I need to accomplish by a house and
get my small business off the ground I
am a generous person but I feel like I'm
being cheap when it comes to giving or
when my wife gets to get something for
her friends or sister I don't feel good
while deep inside I know that I am
I'm kind of confused if I'm changing to
a jerk and a selfish person but honestly
I'm doing it for my family so I need
some help
Jim
you know I mean I think that there's a
reality that when you have
your bases covered in your home and with
your family and the needs are provided
for it allows that generosity to flow
even greater uh with with maybe not as
much stress but this doesn't sound like
it's a I need to take care of my family
first I mean yes you want to be able to
buy a house for sure get my small
business off the ground you know but
this I would say to those gym that that
giving it doesn't have to be extravagant
and so starting to give a little until
you can give a lot right like if there
are things in your life that you're
wanting to do we all have that but that
doesn't mean you can't do both is what I
would say yeah
it sounds like
um
that the uh what's bothering you more
than the actual giving
um to the sister or to the friends or
whatever by your wife is that it feels
like that's blocking these other goals
and it's not that's the reality so the
way you can overcome that is just budget
for it
you say we're going to put a line item
in the budget you and your wife that
agree we agree on our entire budget but
we're going to agree on this is the
amount that that your wife has for
friends and sister
and uh don't go over that and then you
can use the rest of the budget
and see that you are able to accomplish
your goals of doing stuff in the
business or saving up for a home or
whatever you'll see that it you know if
you budget 100 bucks or something it's
not going to keep you from doing those
other things but this idea that it's not
got any limits on it
and um you're not in agreement when
she's doing these things that's where
the rub is so if you were in agreement
and it had a reasonable limit and you
were in agreement on the limit on the
amount that that you know your wife has
for these two activities sister and
friends or whatever you want to call it
uh then you'd be okay with it uh but
it's just the ambivalence of it that is
uh that's probably throwing you because
you're you're obviously a person who who
plans but this is not something it
doesn't make you a bad person to say I'm
going to accomplish some goals
that's that's not a bad person now what
we do teach and have taught from the
very beginning around Ramsey and I think
it's good to get into this a little bit
is you want a baseline of giving that is
your normal rhythm
in your life
uh every month
and then you have when you are are
prospering and you've got extra money
above that normal budgeted giving that's
just flying around and you have a choice
between buying you know another thingy
and doing some generosity then you can
change and and do some generosity with
that Surplus money that extra money
that's from prospering but when you're
first starting out uh we teach people to
limit their giving to their Baseline
normal giving now for those of us that
are uh Christians Evangelical Christians
we teach and believe within our faith to
give a tithe a tenth of our income to
your local church that's your Baseline
that's your normal rhythm of giving you
don't stop doing that
and uh above the tithe is called
offerings and all throughout scripture
offerings come from Surplus from
prospering and so they would come after
you're out of debt
after you've taken care of your own
household
and and so this idea that you're
supposed to give away the rent money
uh and your your kids are become
homeless because you were generous
that's absurd
and it's not scriptural for those of you
that are Christians by the way take care
of your own household first or you're
worse than unbeliever
that's scriptural and that's not lacking
in generosity it doesn't make you a bad
person quite the opposite it makes you a
good person yeah absolutely so we start
with taking care of our house then we
can expand and say we're going to take
care of people outside of our house and
then we can expand and say we're going
to change our family tree and then we
can expand and say let's change our
whole community
but that's that all comes from the
Surplus above the normal rhythm of
giving and I think you need to put a
rhythm of giving Jim in your budget for
your wife to have some freedom without
being worried about you being upset
about it